[Musica]
ho notato un po io
mi piace cantare moltissimo
posso dire che cantare la mia ossessione
i miei genitori mi raccontavano che
quando ero bambina e organizzavamo
classiche domenica in famiglia tipiche
per sud italia
io inseguivo letteralmente i miei
parenti e quando riusciva a bloccarli lì
torturato con la domanda posso tentar di
una canzone
voi penserete che cosa deliziosi
immaginate questa piccola bambina di 3 4
anni alle prese con hai ti sorridono i
monti oppure 44 gatti fila per the
record di 2
il fatto è che poi questa canzone
diventava due tre quattro canzoni e il
pubblico cioè i miei parenti non
potevano minimamente distrarsi
altrimenti le canzoni ricominciano da
capo è l'infanzia che bel periodo no
peccato che dura troppo poco
e d'improvviso mi ritrovo adolescente
con i capelli arruffati davanti al viso
e quell'espressione un penso lente un po
sofferente che tutti gli adolescenti del
mondo anno e mi ritrovo ad amare la
musica che amavano i miei genitori
questa qui
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
chiese
[Musica]
meyer sonora
peccato
no
[Musica]
i target
fare
grazie
voglio strage
boccia
sono tanto bastava soltanto grava sono
brava sono stato brado
così qualche nota non è proprio io sono
fiduciosa che così nessuno simone grillo
un sanpietrino saprà sentire queste nota
così va a casa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh
[Musica]
ho preso male
è vero
[Musica]
e insomma si posso dirlo cantare è
sempre stata il mio modo di comunicare
di esprimermi e se quando ero bambina
avevo sempre e comunque voglia di
cantare di avere sempre comunque voce in
capitolo crescendo per fortuna ho
iniziato ad ascoltarmi un po di più ea
capire cosa fosse giusto comunicare e
cosa no
avere voce in capitolo sì ma solo se
strettamente necessario
ma cosa vuol dire letteralmente avere
voce in capitolo
l'espressione che tutti utilizziamo cioè
avere credito autorità per esprimere
un'opinione un'idea e figurata rispetto
a quella originaria che è propria del
diritto canonico e voleva dire avere
diritto di voto in un capitolo e il
capitolo verosimilmente doveva essere
riconducibile all espressione latina i
read capitolo cioè andare a leggere un
capitolo delle sacre scritture
quindi chi ha voce in capitolo e colui
colei che ha conquistato una
riconosciuta autorevolezza per esprimere
un'opinione un'idea
facile no per niente
non è mai stato facile realtà è
probabilmente non lo sarà mai
prendiamo alcuni esempi nella storia
della musica
anzi del canto i signori incontrastati
del canto dal cinquecento al settecento
dal barocco al melodramma i castrati
[Musica]
come la roma
[Risate]
[Musica]
no
i castrati ica stati erano considerati
delle vere e proprie divinità del canto
perché avevano queste voci potenti e
angelica allo stesso tempo e quindi
erano venerati come delle vere e proprie
e rockstar della loro epoca ma dietro
questo successo si non secondo una
pratica barbara voi immaginate questi
ragazzi questi bambini figli di famiglie
molto povere è molto ambizioso e pronte
a sacrificare uno o più figli per il
benessere economico il prestigio sociale
in questi ragazzi erano costretti a
sottoporsi a un'operazione
rischiosissima spesso fatale e che
comunque li avrebbe privati per sempre
dalla possibilità di avere figli
un sacrificio immenso in nome della fama
del successo della avere voce in
capitolo
alcuni ci riuscirono ma anche prezzo e
se le cose per gli uomini erano
difficili per le donne ma che mondo è
mondo è sempre stato peggio qualche
secolo più tardi dall'altra parte del
pianeta cominciano a nascere il jazz e
incontriamo donne coraggiose che hanno
saputo imporsi come icona in un mondo
maschilista misogino una una delle più
grandi
billie holiday un riferimento assoluto
per tutti e cantante di jazz e non solo
perché ha inventato un nuovo modo di
cantare originale unico ma la sua arte
nasconde i segni di una vita al limite
subisce uno sopra 10 anni ancora bambina
raggiunge la madre a new york e per
guadagnarsi da vivere si prostituisce
la polizia scopre il bordello dove
lavora la resta a 4 mesi di carcere e
quando esce di prigione comincia a
cercare lavoro come ballerina anche se
non sa ballare ma l'assumono subito
quando la sentono cantare
sange paolo anch'io
[Musica]
è una buona causa
voleva cantare billi e lo ha fatto ha
avuto voce in capitolo ma che prezzo
pagato è oggi cosa vuol dire avere voce
in capitolo per una donna oggi cosa vuol
dire essere una professionista essere
una donna oggi sarebbe bello poter dire
che va tutto benissimo
sarebbe bello poter dire che oggi una
donna almeno nel mondo occidentale
perché ovviamente ci sono ancora posti
nel mondo in cui la libertà delle donne
non si può neanche lontanamente
immaginare ma sarebbe bello poter dire
che nel nostro mondo occidentale una
donna oggi può totalmente completamente
tranquillamente essere dire fare pensare
tutto ciò che vuole avere liberamente
voce in capitolo
senza però avere il timore di essere
vittima di pregiudizi ricattini morali e
sociali è vero molti passi avanti sono
stati fatti molte conquiste grazie alle
donne che ci hanno preceduto alle nostre
madri ma non si può ancora passare la
guardia perché oggi il maschilismo non è
più quello becero e arrogante dell'epoca
di billie holiday ma è ancora resistente
presente insidioso si insinua nella
nostra mente e nella mente delle giovani
donne delle donne che adulte ci ripete
continuamente devi essere perfetta degli
essere bellissima devi essere una taglia
38 deve essere intelligente ma modesta
avere sempre la battuta pronta ma stare
al posto tuo e soprattutto di studiare
sudare sgobbare lavorare il doppio il
triplo rispetto al tuo compagno di
classe quando sarai grande rispetto a un
uomo di parità lento o al tuo collega di
lavoro per avere lo stesso
riconoscimento sociale o lo stesso
stipendio e quando incontrerai le
battutine tipo per essere una donna sei
brava oppure la solita cantante oppure
troppo bella per essere intelligente
troppo brutta per essere convincente
troppo alto troppo bassa troppo magra
troppo grassa troppo tu dovrai incassato
sempre col sorriso sulle labbra far
finta che nulla di sconvolga e magari sì
chi verrà a qualche volta voglia di
essere come il mondo ti vuole e allora
farai una dieta troppo drastica o non ti
sentirai all'altezza perché è preso due
chili tuoi capelli non sono in ordine il
tuo sorriso non è perfetto ma forse
forse questa ansia di apparire al meglio
e proprio figlia dei nostri tempi
certo io parlo da donna perché sono una
donna e vivo questa mia esperienza
terrena in un corpo di donna ma l'ansia
di essere perfetti di dimostrare di
saper fare tutto e bene forse ci
accomuna un po tutti donne uomini
giovani adulti
esiste però una via d'uscita una via di
scampo e le parole d'ordine sono due
accettazione e riconciliazione accettare
la nostra fragilità umanità imperfezione
riconciliarci con la meravigliosa idea
di non dover e voler e poter essere
perfetti a tutti i costi che poi
perfezione staticità invece proprio la
nostra natura in perfetta che ci spinge
a cercare ad anelare a desiderare
amiamo dunque la nostra imperfezione
perché è il motore della nostra crescita
e amiamo l'idea che non possiamo
dobbiamo vogliamo piacere a tutti ma che
tutti abbiamo il diritto di farci
sentire anche se intorno ci vogliono
insicuri e muti ecco avere voce in
capitolo non è presunzione arroganza al
contrario è un atto di onestà
intellettuale che ci permette di
riconoscerci come pari uguali nelle
nostre differenze c'è una sola regola
però che non si può davvero infrangere
ed è quella della verità avere voce in
capitolo
vuol dire dire la verità vuol dire
essere liberi di esprimersi nel lavoro
nella vita negli affetti e il dovere di
farlo con verità e onestà verso gli
altri e verso l'unica persona alla quale
non possiamo davvero mentire
noi stessi tutti
abbiamo in senso reale l'auto figurato
una voce e tutti siamo chiamati a farla
sentire tutti dobbiamo prendere con
coraggio e fiducia questo rotolo di
pergamena salire sul capitolo della vita
e dire questa è la mia voce
questo sono io
e ora vorrei cantarvi una mia canzone
che parla in un certo senso del dir la
verità in un momento speciale della
nostra vita
quando ci innamoriamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non calciato
e le parole carica non sai
per l'anziano
nessun ci diranno modiano tiene a freno
un po renzo
[Musica]
e lo sanno
la storia pare donna segna
arouca tipo io amo ciari una storia
quorum
[Musica]
ecco tra le ciglia di carica
amore
[Musica]
oggi ha confessato
tipo
[Musica]
angelo di leonforte
[Applauso]
[Musica]